Is your property
yours?
Not if government takes it.
And it can for
what it calls public use.
Eminent domain law has long allowed
politicians to grab your property to
build roads,
railroad tracks,
border walls.
Which helps explain why
President Trump told Bret Baier,
"I think eminent domain is wonderful."
I get it that a highway
or a border wall
is public use,
but 13 years ago the Supreme Court ruled
that New London, Connecticut
could bulldoze this little pink house
to make room
for a new business development.
Eminent domain.
They can take your home,
they can take your land.
In this soon-to-be released movie,
Catherine Keener plays Susetto Kelo,
the owner of that little pink house,
here learning that she has no right
to her own property.
How could somebody break into my house
and take everything I have and go to jail?
Oh you could shoot him.
I could shoot him!
I could kill them.
But if they want the whole thing it's perfectly legal.
The law does require the government
to give you fair value for your property
But the bureaucrats decide
what fair value is.
Mrs. Kelo! I have great news
They've agreed to increase their offer by $10,000.
Susette Kelo didn't want the money.
She wanted to keep her home,
but the government said no.
So the bulldozers came.
90 families left
Susette and six others refused to leave.
While this was going on,
I interviewed the real-life Kelo.
We were backed into corners,
like animals in a corner.
I gave the city's lawyer a hard time about that.
Any group of politicians can kick you out of your home.
Well, that's true,
but that's true if you want to put up a road
for example,
the question is,
is this serving an important
public purpose
and we say it is.
It's giving them a lot of power.
Yes, that's true.
A libertarian law firm,
The Institute for Justice took Susette's case
all the way to the U.S. Supreme Court,
where Justice Sandra Day O'Connor
pushed back against the taking.
Say you had a Motel 6
and the city says,
well if we had a Ritz-Carlton
we would have higher taxes.
Now is that okay?
Yes, Your Honor that would be okay.
So you can take from A to give to B
if B pays more taxes?
If it is a significant amount,
yes.
Susette's lawyer responded this way:
The one thing that all poor neighborhoods share
is that they don't produce much tax revenue.
If the court affirms the lower court's decision,
then you would put poor neighborhoods
and working-class neighborhoods like Fort Trumbull
in jeopardy.
He was right.
But the Supreme Court ruled
5-4 against Susette.
U.S. Supreme Court today affirmed the power
of local governments to seize private property.
The decision alarmed people
across America.
Some states passed laws
limiting their politicians right to grab your property.
In New London,
people rallied around Susette.
Hands off her home! Hands off her home!
Thank you all for fighting so hard.
But that fight was over.
They'd lost.
Years later,
I went with Susette Kelo to
look at the place
New London said was going to be a
"booming development".
This was my stairs
and I had a long porch,
and this is where the house was.
The city said they had to tear the houses down
because development would happen,
tax revenues
all kinds of cool new things
and yet,
this is what they got.
No hotel or upscale housing,
no conference center,
no nothing.
Kelo's house has been torn down
and the lot where it once stood is vacant.
It's still empty.
Even today
13 years later, there's no development.
It's just unused land.
The politicians were wrong.
This new movie is a good reminder
of just how powerful
and wrong
politicians often are.